the eyes to the right 242 the nose to
the left 391 is to the right
240 to the nose to the left 391 so the
noes have it the noes have it
I'm not another thumping defeat you can
see it there nearly a hundred and fifty
a majority against the Prime Minister
it's going to make a statement
on a point of order mr. speaker i
profoundly regret the decision that this
house has taken tonight I continue to
believe that by far the best outcome is
the United Kingdom leaves the European
Union in an orderly fashion with a deal
and that the deal we've negotiated is
the best and indeed the only deal
available but Mr Speaker I would like to
set out briefly how the government means
to proceed two weeks ago I made a series
of commitments from this despatch-box
regarding the steps we would take in the
event this house rejected the deal on
offer by standby those commitments in
full
therefore tonight we will table a motion
for debate tomorrow to test whether the
house supports leaving the European
Union without a deal on the 29th of
March the leader of the house will
shortly make an emergency business
statement confirming the change to
tomorrow his business this is an issue
of grave importance for the future of
our country just like the referendum
there are strongly held and equally
legitimate views on both sides for that
reason I can confirm that this will be a
free vote on this side of the house
I can I have firstly struggled with this
choice as I'm sure many other own were
members will I'm passionate about
delivering the result of the referendum
but I equally passionately believe that
the best way to do that is to leave in
an orderly way with a deal and I still
believe that there is a majority in the
house for that course of action and I'm
conscious also and I'm conscious also of
my duties as Prime Minister of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland and of the potential
damage to the Union that leaving without
City who could do when one part of our
country is without devolved governments
I can therefore confirm that the motion
will read that this has declines to
approve leaving the European Union
without a withdrawal agreement and a
framework on the future relationship on
the 29th of March 2019 and notes that
leaving without a deal remains the
default in UK and EU law unless this
house and the EU ratify an agreement I
will return to the house to open the
debate tomorrow and take interventions
multiple members and to ensure the house
is fully informed in making this
historic decision the government will
tomorrow publish information on
essential policies which would need to
be put in place if we were to leave
without a deal these will cover our
approach to tariffs and for Northern
Ireland border among other matters if
the House votes to leave without a deal
on the 29th of March it will be the
policy of the government to implement
that decision if the house declines to
approve leaving without a deal on the
29th of March the government will
following that vote bring forward a
motion on Thursday on whether Parliament
wants to seek an extension to article 50
if the House votes were an extension the
government will seek to agree that
extension with the EU and bring forward
the necessary legislation to change the
exit date commensurate with that
extension but let me be clear voting
against leaving without a deal and for
an extension
does not solve the problems we face
the EU the EU will want to know what use
we mean to make such an extension and
this house will have to answer that
question does it wish to revoke article
50 does it want to hold a second
referendum
[Applause]
does it want does it want to leave with
a deal but not this deal these are an
enviable choices but thanks to the
decision that the house has made this
evening
they are choices that must now be faced